[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de suite
le sommaire de ce mercredi 2 novembre
le scarabée à la verrière résonnera des
rythmes rock et des petites bourrettes
le groupe français était en résidence la
semaine dernière pour les dix ans de la
mort de l'humoriste la fondation raymond
devos a investi l'âme demeure de
l'artiste pour en faire un musée il sera
inauguré le 7 novembre prochain et le
gang des antilles et qui retrace
l'histoire de jim et la rivière un
martinique 1 arrivé en métropole dans
son adolescence sort le 30 novembre
prochain il a été produit par un saint
quentinois nous avons assisté à l'avant
première il s'adresse aux personnes
âgées de 7 à 77 ans un peu comme les
jeux de société les petites bourrettes
un groupe de musique français est en
résidence au scarabée de la verrière du
26 au 30 octobre et le 4 novembre
prochain un concert est prévu pour
marquer la fin de cette résidence les
petites bourrettes c'est du rock de la
musique française l'accordéon des textes
et de l'humour regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
les jurés
il chante l'amour la vie la mort des
amis qui font du rock après les rues du
xviiie arrondissement de paris les
petites bourrettes sont sur les routes
françaises depuis 15 ans on a commencé
dans une formule un peu acoustique
musique de rue
à une époque où à paris c'est un peu
compliqué de faire des concerts
amplifiés donc nous on se tient peu
adapté en faisant une formule plus
acoustique quoi et après l'udc ont
proposé de jouer sur des plus gros sel
on a un peu électrifié notre son du 26
au 30 octobre il était en résidence à la
verrière quatre jours pour travailler
leur tournée 2010 est inspiré par leur
nouvel album et c'est encore
[Musique]
oh
c'est là où même si de l'extérieur on
peut avoir l'impression qu'on fout rien
ou pas grand chose en voyant tous en
train de cogiter un moment et se passe
un truc et si les trois premiers jours
on regarde le plan des quatrième et
cinquième est à fond joue à huit heures
par jour et ça finit par donner quelque
chose intéressante c'est là on progresse
c'est vraiment parce qu'il faut pas
croire que qu'il n'y a pas de marge de
progrès ou qu'on est donc
le fait de jouer plus fin plus tu joues
tu t'es bon coach et voilà c'est
l'occasion dû beaucoup en peu de temps
un nouveau concert à découvrir le 4
novembre au scarabée classique et
nouvelles chansons sont au programme du
rock des balades de la valse musette les
petites bourrettes s'adresse à tout le
monde tant qu'ils s'amusent
[Musique]
toujours en musique la pms qu
l'association pour la promotion de la
musique à saint quentin en yvelines lens
ce week-end sa saison de la musique
classique comme chaque année que
l'association cherche à faire découvrir
au public saint quentinois le samedi 5
novembre l'auditorium de trappes
accueillera le quatuor les dissonances
je laisse hervé farges le président de
l'association présenter cette soirée
c'est un quatuor qui est mondialement
connue pour vous dire il se produit
régulièrement à la philharmonie de paris
se produit dans le monde entier
à sa tête c'est david grimal qui est un
très très grand violoniste ils vont
interpréter trois oeuvres donc deux
oeuvres très connues qui sont des
pourrait dire des tubes en musique de
chambre donc un quatuor de beethoven et
puis le quatuor qui a été créée en 1806
ce moment aux baies tough commençait à
avoir est atteint de surdité et un
quatuor de schubert et là c'est le
dernier quatuor de schubert au moment où
il savait qu'il allait mourir
il y a tout juste dix ans raymond devos
moorea saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse pour lui
rendre hommage la fondation qui porte
son nom a décidé de mettre en place un
musée au sein même de la demeure de l'ue
de l'artiste ce musée ouvrira ses portes
au public la semaine prochaine je vous
propose une première découverte sur des
images de lucile decker
il vous accueille en personne disparue
depuis dix ans raymond devos a légué ses
sous réunis en un musée au sein même de
sa demeure une volonté de l'artiste la
mairie à l'époque légataire universel
avait pour mission de mettre en place
une fondation qui elle-même mettra en
oeuvre tout ce qu'il fallait pour
l'ouverture d'un musée dans sa maison le
but des aménagements de ce musée sont
d'en faire un lieu de vie vidéo et audio
puisque ça correspond au caractère de
l'artiste qui était raymond devos dans
cette maison achetée en 1963 raymond
devos sucré ce sketch une atmosphère
décliné dans les différentes pièces du
musée dans ce musée on peut voir les
pièces maîtresses en tant que pièce
architecture c'est-à-dire son bureau qui
a été reconstitués d'après photos et son
petit musée les autres pièces maîtresses
ce sont les
distinction qu'il a reçu les prix qu'il
a reçu et puis tous les objets kim dont
il se servait plus exactement pour ses
sketchs on peut voir dans cette maison
d'abord sa maison on y regarder son
bureau son petit musée la bibliothèque
de sa salle à manger et dans les autres
pièces il y aura des éléments de vidéo
et audio pour voir ses sketches entendre
la préparation des sketches et puis ils
découvrirent un certain nombre d'objets
du cirque notamment avec lesquels il
habillait ses sketches elle la
maison-musée peaufine son installation
la découverte de la vie de raymond devos
sera possible à partir du 7 novembre
on ouvre maintenant une page cinéma
lancé l'an dernier le festival de la
bande annonce revient pour une seconde
édition à bois d'arcy président et est
parrainée par le journaliste et
animateur télé vincent perrot ce
festival présentera une cinquantaine de
bande annonce avant d'échanger avec le
public ecoutez jean philippe plus l'élu
de la commune en charge de la culture
l'objectif justement être pas faire un
festival trop cinéphiles et justement
ouvert au grand public donc il y aura
notamment une des premières bandes
annonces officielles qui date des années
1920 en partenariat avec le cnc mais il
y aura aussi des films récents mois
récents connus ou moins connus du grand
public il valoir des thématiques autour
du western notamment où la comédie est
toujours est toujours on y tient
d'ailleurs des nouveautés à des bandes
annonces en exclusivité pour donner
envie aux anciens et aux gens qui vont
venir à ce festival d'aller au cinéma
tout au long de l'année prochaine
vendredi dernier l'espace philippe
noiret des clayes-sous-bois projeté en
avant première le gang des antilles et
le film réalisé par jean claude barny
raconte l'histoire de jimmy la rivière
un jeune mattie antilles est arrivé en
métropole à l'âge de 13 ans dans les
années 70 les sdf et tentent de survivre
avec sa fille la diffusion du film aux
clayes-sous-bois n'est pas anodine le
producteur sébastien onomo il vit
c'est une façon de dire merci à la ville
sébastien onomo et producteur et
scénariste
vendredi 28 octobre clayes-sous-bois il
présentait aux spectateurs le gang des
antillais j'ai commencé ici aux
clayes-sous-bois un tourner des courts
métrages et une soutien de la ville sur
sur différents projets et comment j'en
suis arrivée à faire de la production
par une par une du jir n y fera simple
qui est on n'est jamais mieux servi que
par soi même assez rapidement en fait on
a été convaincu par le potentiel du film
pour plusieurs raisons parce que d'abord
c'est un film qui parlait d'un aspect
méconnu de l'histoire française qui est
le demi d'hommes s'étaient fait une
bonne dizaine de bureaux de poste je me
sentais comme un smicard dioulde
besoin demandez je voulais plus du petit
doigt l'état je vous laisse hamad tout
entière
braquage de bureaux de poste racisme et
pantalons pattes d'éléphant c'est une
plongée dans la france métropolitaine
des années 1970 en plein boom et
d'hommes quand de nombreux autres marins
arrive en métropole
[Applaudissements]
les habitants de la martinique de la
guadeloupe et de la haine
le gang des antilles et raconte
l'histoire de jimmy la rivière inspiré
du récit autobiographique de l'eau et
qu'il est riche en présente ce film
témoigne d'une véracité historique ça
c'est sûr mais ce fut aussi une portée
beaucoup plus plus universel parce que
rester que seule histoire n'aurait
concerné évidemment que ceux qui
s'intéressent mais on avait en tout cas
envie
c'est bastia et
dont les films d'ici et moi de faire un
vrai film un vrai film qui avait une
portée au delà de l'histoire au delà des
personnages quelque chose qui peut être
un outil afin peut-être pédagogique mais
aussi un outil de cinéma le film a reçu
le hublot d'or du festival de la page à
l'image du croisic les aventures du gang
des antilles et sont à découvrir à
partir du 30 novembre prochain
[Musique]
on reste aux clayes-sous-bois puisque le
coût de car siné de cette semaine c'est
celui de cyril adan de l'espace fille
noire et il est question d'odyssée
sous-marine regarder
cette semaine notre coup de coeur et le
film l'odyssée réalisé par jérôme salle
avec lambert wilson audrey tautou et
pierre niney
1948 jacques yves cousteau sa femme et
ses deux fils vivent au paradis dans une
jolie maison surplombant la méditerranée
mais cousteau ne rêvent que d'aventurés
grâce à son invention un scaphandre
autonome qui permet de respirer sous
l'eau il a découvert un nouveau monde
désormais ce monde ils veulent explorer
et pour ça il est prêt à tout sacrifier
la réalisation tendu la beauté des
images le montage rythmé et la bande son
envoûtante accompagne des acteurs
bluffante qu'il s'agisse aussi bien de
pierre niney audrey tautou
impressionnante épouse du commandant
quant à lambert wilson il compose un
cousteau à la fois époustouflant
séduisant cassant et blessés les
spectateurs découvriront deux sublimes
prises de vues sous-marines et seront
transportés dans un magnifique voyage à
travers le club étonnant et somptueux le
film de jérôme salle nous fait découvrir
des aspects méconnus de la personnalité
du commandant cousteau le commandant
cousteau et son équipage se lie d'amitié
avec des animaux sauvages mais c'est
super c'est génial bravo c
mao
ma
une association de
la tête sous l'eau
l'immensité à pureté
l'odyssée est à découvrir cette semaine
à l'espace philippe le ray
[Musique]
comme chaque semaine plusieurs rendez
vous le premier c'est la dernière ligne
droite pour notre jeu concours vous avez
jusqu'au 3 novembre pour gagner des
places pour le concert d'eric truffaz et
oxmo puccino un tirage au sort aura lieu
rendez vous sur la page facebook de tv
fil 78 la semaine prochaine ce sera la
commémoration de la grande guerre à
cette occasion la ville des
clayes-sous-bois organise plusieurs
événements à nos morts est une pièce de
théâtre urbain teinté de danse hip hop
elle est à découvrir le 10 novembre
prochain regardez cet extrait
quand le hip hop sort de sa caricature
quand il se sublime pour devenir poésie
urbaine conte moderne outil de
transmission quand il est un appel aux
souvenirs à la justice à la fraternité
quand il est un hommage en mots en danse
en musique et en images hommage à la
mémoire enfui des tirailleurs alors il
devient accessible est nécessaire à tous
à nos morts un fragment d'histoire celle
de ses soldats sénégalais maliens
ivoiriens burkinabé malgache marocains
algériens tunisiens du shinobi indigènes
raflé ou engagés volontaires
pour ceux qui s'est souhaité avoir la
tête dans les étoiles l'exposition
infinie intimes est pour vous jusqu'au
18 décembre la commanderie des templiers
expose le travail du gouverneur le
plasticien et artiste numérique français
réalise des installations mêlant univers
mathématiques et sculptures le 7-8
culture est maintenant terminée je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis les
magazines continue sur tv fil 78 et moi
je vous dis à mercredi prochain
[Musique]